تلقى امير دوله قطر الشيخ تميم بن حمد ال
ثاني رساله خطيه من العهد الاردني للملك
عبد الله الثاني تتصل بالعلاقات الثنائيه
بين قطر والاردن واوجه دعمها وتعزيزها
خلال لقاء في الدوحه بين امير دوله قطر
الشيخ
ورئيس الوزراء الاردني بشر الخصاونه او
قلب بيان للديوان الاميري القطري انه جرى
خلال لقاء استعراض العلاقات الوطيده بين
قطر والاردن وسبل تعزيزها وتنميتها
هذا وقال رئيس مجلس الوزراء وزير الخارجيه
القطري الشيخ محمد بن عبد الرحمن الثاني
له ناقش مع رئيس الوزراء الاردني بشر
الخصاونه خلال لقائهما في الدوحه العلاقات
الثنائيه والتطورات المقلقه في القدس
والمنطقه اضاف رئيس مجلس
المتفق خلال لقاء على استكمال جهود خفض
التصعيد ودعم الصمود الشعب الفلسطيني